Stefani Germanotta tried a subtler approach to the music business.
For a while, I had this very long brown hair...
...and I was really into Bob Dylan, and Jefferson Airplane, and Grace Slick.
I was doing just a different kind of music.
It was not until she changed her sound and became Lady Gaga, that her career took off.
With the success of her debut CD, The Fame,...
...she has gone from a struggling singer-songwriter to a headliner...
...with a well-known opening act.
It is a privilege to be here tonight to open for Lady Gaga.
President Obama made the remarks at a dinner,...
...sponsored by a group promoting equal rights for gays and lesbians.
Lady Gaga is a vocal supporter of that cause.
Her success might seem sudden...
...but the groundwork was laid by years of music lessons,...
...and performing in local clubs for little money.
I mean, I've been playing piano since I was four and been studying...
...and whether it was in music theory classes, or I was in jazz band, or writing music,...
...and around 14, I started to play out in local clubs.
My mother would take me and sign me up on the open mic night sheet.
I could tell the story forever but really it's just that I never gave up,...
...and music has always been my destiny.